[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers
in allen guten Abend am Ende einer Woche
in der sich Deutschland auf einen Weg
begeben hat zu dem die einen den Kanzler
drängten und vor dem andere große Sorge
haben Kampfpanzer für die Ukraine das
ist ein großer Schritt da sind sich alle
einig wohin er uns führt und welches
Szenarien sich jetzt ergeben auch wie
dieser Krieg enden kann darauf wollen
wir heute gucken nach vorne wir beginnen
in der Ukraine selbst wo sie natürlich
jede Lieferung moderner Waffen begrüßen
erwarten fordern und die aus Deutschland
noch mal speziell wie Katrin Eigendorf
zeigt sie ist in der Nähe der Frontlinie
bei der Stadt bachmut
im frühen Morgengrauen an der Frontlinie
von bachmut wir folgen ukrainischen
Soldaten zu einer Artilleriestellung
seit Sommer haben Sie hier eine
Panzerhaubitze aus Deutschland im
Einsatz die Soldaten wurden in
Deutschland geschult wie hat der Einsatz
der hobbitse die Situation verändert
sehr stark früher haben wir mit
sowjetischen zwei Spionen gearbeitet im
Vergleich zu dieser Technik ist diese
viel schneller manövriert besser die
Schüsse erfolgen viel schneller und sie
sind viel präziser
die Technik ist gut aber geht kaputt was
Deutschland angeht das war super alles
hat mir gut gefallen man hat uns gut
geschult ich bin sehr zufrieden dass ich
da gewesen bin Erfahrung gesammelt habe
das hilft uns jetzt sehr genau
für den Einsatz fahren die Militärs die
Haubitze aufs offene Feld ihr Ziel sind
russische Panzereinheiten und auch
Artillerie sie stehen nur acht Kilometer
von hier entfernt die Soldaten warnen
uns gleich wird es extrem laut werden
in den Po treffen wir den Sprecher des
Militärkommandos Ost sarici
[Musik]
für uns wäre es ideal wenn wir noch
Flugzeuge hätten Militärhubschrauber wir
nehmen alles dankbar an und nutzen es
das sind Investitionen nicht nur in
unsere Sicherheit sondern von ganz
Europa wir verlieren leider sehr viele
Menschenleben
ja wie dramatisch sich die Lage in der
Region jetzt entwickelt erleben wir noch
am gleichen Tag den konstantinufer
russische Raketen schlagen mitten in ein
Wohnviertel ein wieder sterben drei
Menschen die Zerstörung geht weiter
am Waldrand fahren die Soldaten die
Haubitze in ein geschütztes Versteck
zurück eine ihrer größten Sorgen ist
dass sie Technik von russischen Militärs
entdeckt wird auch deshalb sollen wir
nicht zu lange bleiben doch einen Blick
ins Innere der Haubitze dürfen wir
werfen Genia erklärt warum es hier
besonders gefährlich ist
weil wir hier in der Nähe von bachmut
sind wir verteidigen bachmut das ist der
heißeste Punkt
als wir den Stützpunkt verlassen ist in
der Ferne bereits wieder russische
Artillerie zu hören der Angriff auf die
Stadt geht weiter
der vergangene Montag ist ja nicht so
wahnsinnig lange her aber es kommt einem
so vor wenn man sich anguckt was
passiert ist seitdem Montag da gilt der
Bundeskanzler nach langen Debatten noch
als Zauderer kein Jahr kein nein wenn es
um die Frage geht wird Deutschlands
Kampfpanzer liefern oder auch nur
gestatten das andere sie liefern
Dienstag sickert durch die Haltung
ändert sich und zwar entscheidend und
nicht nur in Berlin Mittwoch offiziell
gilt jetzt Deutschland wird liefern als
Teil einer neuen panzerkoalition auch
mit den USA der Kanzler lehnt noch
weitergehende Waffenlieferungen strikt
ab neue Forderungen liegen da bereits
auf dem Tisch der ukrainische Präsident
bittet unter anderem um Kampf Flugzeuge
andere bitten bringen Fregatten und
U-Boote ins Spiel wo wird das hinführen
einer der sich intensiv Gedanken macht
wie ein Ende des Krieges aussehen könnte
ist der Osteuropa Forscher Hans Henning
Schröder er beschäftigt sich sein ganzes
akademisches Leben mit dem politischen
Wandel in Russland mit sowjetischer und
russischer außen und Sicherheitspolitik
Herr Professor guten Abend guten Abend
Herr Sievers ein Ende des Krieges bevor
wir auf eine konkrete Strategie die mehr
möglicherweise in diese Richtung führen
könnte kommen zunächst vielleicht diese
Woche und ihre Entwicklung Panzer aus
dem Westen Deutschland USA ist das aus
ihrer Sicht eine Eskalation die man
eingehen kann und möglicherweise auch
muss oder der entscheidende Schritt zu
viel
ja es ist eine Eskalation die man
eingehen kann und ich denke auch dass
man als muss was wir wollen ist eine
Europa das auch Verträgen basiert eine
Sicherheitsarchitektur bei dem man sich
ohne alle Konflikte politisch löst und
nicht militärisch das geht aber nur wenn
man Russland daran hindert die Ukraine
niederzuwerfen das heißt man muss die
Ukraine stärken und das tun wir auch
zuletzt jetzt mit diesen Kampfpanzern
das heißt wenn ich sie da zusammenfassen
darf Panzer aus ihrer Sicht verhindern
nicht Verhandlungen sie sind quasi eine
Art Voraussetzung dafür ja das Ziel ist
sind Verhandlung aber dazu muss Russland
erstmal in den Stand gebracht werden das
ist auch verhandeln will das ist im
Moment nicht der Fall und ich denke mit
deiner Verstärkung der Unterstützung für
die Ukraine bringen wir Russland in
diese Richtung wie sehen denn dann
solche Verhandlungen aus haben sie dafür
eine Skizze einen eine Überlegungen in
welche Richtung die gehen müssten ich
denke schon darüber denken im Moment
viele Leute nach der erste Punkt ist
natürlich Einstellung der
Kampfhandlungen dass es etwas was die
Ukraine und Russland miteinander
ausmachen müssen aber dann brauchen wir
eine Sicherheitsarchitektur für Europa
das heißt da müssten dann die NATO
Russland auch die postowitischen Staaten
mit am Tisch sitzen und müssten darüber
nachdenken wie kann man Sicherheit
garantieren in Europa parallel müssten
die USA und und Russland aushandeln die
nukleare Sicherheit sowohl im
strategischen Bereich also
intercontialraketen wie im
kontinentalbereich also bitte
streckenraketen all das muss sozusagen
einander greifen und begleiten muss man
das so wie das auch in den 80er Jahren
der Fall war durch Maßnahmen zur
Vertrauensbildung weil ein Problem dass
wir jetzt haben ist dass wir mit einer
russischen Führung zu tun haben der man
eigentlich nicht mehr vertrauen kann
und das ja da sprechen Sie jetzt selber
an deswegen wie sollten denn dann
Maßnahmen zur Vertrauensbildung wie sie
die jetzt nennen tatsächlich konkret
aussehen also das ist natürlich erstmal
eine Frage der Respektierung von Grenzen
ein wichtiger Schritt zu
Vertrauensbildung wäre wenn Russland
seine Truppen zurückziehen würde aber
darüber hinaus geht es auch darum
Rüstungsbegrenzung zu machen die uns
verifiziert werden es muss kontrolliert
werden es gab mal sowas wie open sky
also dass man mit Vorankündigung über
das Territorium einer anderen macht
fliegen konnte um zu sehen sozusagen was
ich dort militärisch tut also solche
Maßnahmen und da gibt es einen ganz
breiten Fächer ein Strauß vom Maßnahmen
das müsste man sozusagen langsam alles
wieder sozusagen in Gang bringen und es
ist ein langer Weg kann ich ihn jetzt
schon sagen
1961 nach der Kuba-Krise hat es 12 Jahre
gebraucht bis man 1975 das Helsinki
Abkommen dann tatsächlich Schloss also
wir reden hier über einen Zeitraum von
vielen Jahren
ein langer Weg sie haben ja gerade auch
schon verschiedene Akteure skizziert die
daran teilnehmen müssten das ist ja
offensichtlich richtig ein weltweiter
Ansatz den sie da das Wort sprechen
gibt es etwas mit dem man auch jetzt
aktuell schon beginnen könnte
man kann in vielen Punkten beginnen die
Ukraine und Russland haben ja schon
begonnen mit Gefangenenaustausch da gibt
es ja auch irgendwie eine Verbindung
gleichzeitig über die Türkei mit dem
Getreideexport und so kann man denke ich
sich viele relativ kleine Dinge nehmen
die erstmal funktionieren müssen das
wäre auch schon ein Schritt hin zu
Vertrauensbildung
ist Ihnen denn klar welche Rolle
Deutschland bei all dem spielt wir haben
ja jetzt erlebt die Kommunikation des
Kanzlers ist in der Sache äußerst
spärlich und das offenbar mit voller
Absicht der hat jetzt gesagt im
Bundestag vertraut der Regierung quasi
ist das aus ihrer Sicht jetzt ein
schlauer Schritt oder verliert man so
den Rückhalt für die Politik bei Fragen
von Leben und Tod und dieses Jahr geht
es geht ja um zwei Dinge es geht einmal
um den Zusammenhalt in der Bundesliga
selber also die Wähler die deutsche
Bevölkerung auf die schaut er glaube ich
aber wir müssen ja auch die ersten die
Letten die Litauer die Polen ähm die die
Franzosen im Boot haben das heißt es
kann ja nicht kein Alleingang
Deutschlands geben die sozusagen Seite
an Seite mit den USA Politik machen
sondern und dafür ist glaube ich
Kommunikation auch gegenüber den
Verbündeten sehr wichtig sagt der
Osteuropa Forscher Hans Henning Schröder
Herr Professor vielen Dank für das
Gespräch heute Abend
und das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen kurz vor dieser Sendung
aufgezeichnet
weniger Bürokratie das ist eine
Forderung auf die sich in der Politik
alle immer ganz schnell einigen können
das Problem was wir tatsächlich erleben
sieht häufig ganz anders aus immer mehr
Bürokratie immer mehr Formulare immer
mehr Regelungen aktuell sitzen Millionen
Eigentümer von Immobilien an ihrer
grundsteuererklärung etwa 65% haben sie
bereits abgegeben weitere Millionen
müssen also noch liefern wie viele davon
kurz vor dem verzweifeln sind geht aus
der Statistik nicht hervor
fairerweise muss man sagen dass nicht
die Politik allein daran schuld ist
Deutschlands höchstes Gericht hatte das
alte System für verfassungswidrig
erklärt und eine Neubewertung nötig
gemacht und für die das ist ja der
ultimative Schrecken beim Umgang mit der
Verwaltung läuft jetzt die Frist ab
peter griechel hat Post von der
Stadtverwaltung bekommen die ersten
Grundsteuerbescheide sind da Herr
Kriechel ist Winzer und hat viele
Grundstücke die Erklärung abzugeben war
für ihn eine Qual
war alles sehr sehr viel wir haben
bestimmt hier und da wirklich ganz ganz
großen Dank an meine Frau bestimmt 80
Stunden Arbeit reingesteckt um das alles
abzuarbeiten die hat natürlich liebend
gern auch woanders für eingesetzt
besonders kompliziert genau zu trennen
was privat und was betrieblich genutzt
wird sein Weingut ist alles auf einmal
Verkaufsraum Lager ein Mietshaus im Hof
und persönlicher Wohnbereich vorne
hatten wir dann einmal die betriebliche
Nutzung mit der Vinothek der Vater
obendrüber in der privaten Wohnung hier
wieder alles betrieblich genutzt
komplett unterkellert auch der Hof ist
unter kellert betrieblich genutzt und
dann haben wir noch ein Haus hier direkt
hinter uns was im Erdgeschoss wieder um
und im Keller betriebliche Nutzung hat
und oben dann erst der zweite Etage dann
noch
privat bzw vermietet ist alles muss
ausgemessen berechnet und dann in das
Formular übertragen werden es ist
kompliziert nur
65,5% der Eigentümer haben bislang ihre
grundsteuererklärung abgegeben zentrales
Problem jetzt bei diesem aktuellen
Grundsteuer Drama ist wirklich wieder
mal die fehlende Digitalisierung in der
Verwaltung und natürlich auch dass viel
Arbeit im Steuerbürger aufgelastet wird
obwohl viele Daten bei Katasterämtern
bei Finanzämtern etc vorliegen aber hier
keine wirksame Daten Verknüpfung erfolgt
nicht überall werden übrigens dieselben
Daten abgefragt elf Bundesländer hier
hellblau Verfahren nach dem bundesmodell
die anderen fünf haben jeweils eigene
Modelle
kompliziert oder nicht auch für die
Steuerämter ist die grundsteuererklärung
eine Herausforderung wir haben einen
sehr großes Paket zu stemmen 36
Millionen Grundstücke in ganz
Deutschland müssen bewertet werden den
Rheinland-Pfalz 2,5 Millionen das ist
viel und wir müssen ein neues
Bewertungsrecht beachten wir müssen neue
Software einsetzen
feststeht bis übermorgen werden nicht
alle 36 Millionen Erklärungen vorliegen
drastische Strafen drohen zwar erstmal
nicht aber wenn wir die Erklärung vom
Steuerpflichtigen so heißt der bei uns
nicht bekommen dann müssen wir am Ende
selber den Wert schätzen und die
Schätzung ist dann vielleicht nicht so
günstig vom Wert her wie das was man
selber erklären würde
für Peter Kriechel ist das Thema
Grundsteuer ein für alle Mal
abgeschlossen meine Frau und ich sagte
er wollen den Ordner mit den Unterlagen
nie wieder aufklappen
schön einstauben lassen hoffentlich
kommt da nicht doch noch mal was und
dann noch mal dieser Hinweis sehr
wichtig übermorgen läuft die Frist ab
und Ansage der Finanzämter sie die Frist
sie wird nicht verlängert
eins du hast jetzt seine ersten
Überblick über das was auch noch wichtig
ist heute der Bundeskanzler Scholz ist
auf Südamerika Reise es geht unter
anderem um neue Partnerschaften im
Bereich Rohstoffe und Energie erste
Station war Argentinien Scholz Warp nach
den Gesprächen mit Präsident Alberto
Fernandes für einen baldigen Abschluss
des Freihandelsabkommens zwischen der EU
und dem südamerikanischen Staaten und
Merkur
von Argentinien reist Scholz weiter nach
Chile und dann nach Brasilien
CDU-Chef Merz sieht in der Partei keinen
Platz mehr für den ehemaligen
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten Hans-Georg
Maaßen der wegen umstrittener Äußerungen
in der Kritik steht März sagte der Bild
am Sonntag man habe Maßen aufgefordert
die Partei zu verlassen ein Ausschluss
sei nicht ganz einfach aber es werde
gerade geprüft welche Möglichkeiten man
habe
nach den jüngsten Anschlägen hat israels
Regierung neue anti-terrorregeln
beschlossen laut Kabinettsbeschluss
sollen Angehörigen von Attentätern
weitere Rechte entzogen werden können
Israelis sollen außerdem leichter
Lizenzen für Schusswaffen bekommen am
Freitag hat er ein Palästinenser sieben
Menschen vor einer Synagoge in
osttirolering erschossen
in Iran sind bei einem Erdbeben
mindestens drei Menschen ums Leben
gekommen und mehr als 800 wurden
verletzt das Bild der Stärke 5,9
ereignete sich gestern Abend im
Nordwesten des Landes nahe der Grenze
zur Türkei zahlreiche Gebäude wurden
beschädigt und aus Angst vor Nachbeben
blieben zehntausende Familien trotz
Minustemperaturen im Freien
in Frankreich in Österreich in
Tschechien und Großbritannien gucken sie
mit Stolz auf ihre Hauptstadt und wer
selbst nicht in Paris Wien Prag oder
London lebt vielleicht auch mit ein
bisschen Neid in Deutschland schütteln
wir den Kopf Berlin macht Schlagzeilen
die kaum zu fassen sind ich rede nicht
nur von chronisch überforderten Ämtern
die beim Personalausweis irre
Wartezeiten haben und auch
Sterbeurkunden nur mit trauriger Wochen
langer Verspätung ausstellen ich rede
nicht nur von einem Flughafen der
international zur Lachnummer wurde
selbst die Basis einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft eine ordnungsgemäß
die Stadt erlebt jetzt einen neuen
Wahlkampf und die Menschen dort ein
weiteres Mal dieses spezielle
berlingefühl zwischen tiefer
Verzweiflung und immer wieder
aufflackernder Liebe trotz allem Stefan
Merseburger
schon wieder Wahlen dieselben Gesichter
zur Auswahl Berlin muss wieder an die
Urnen zu katastrophal ja beschämend war
was vor anderthalb Jahren passiert ist
viele verschmähen Berlin als Fail City
als gescheiterte Stadt
fail City ist ein bisschen übertrieben
aber es geht schon stark in die Richtung
Lorenz Marold Chefredakteur des
Tagesspiegel seit 30 Jahren zitiert er
die Berliner Landespolitik die Stadt ist
sehenden Auges in das Unheil gerannt
Marathon am Wahltag Bundestagswahl
außerdem die Wahlen zu Abgeordnetenhaus
und Bezirksversammlungen dazu der
Volksentscheid über Enteignungen Komplex
es gab Warnungen zu Haufen Vorfeld
Berlin hat sie in den Wind geblasen wird
schon gut gehen und der politisch
Verantwortliche Andreas Geisel damals
innen heute Bausenator ist immer noch im
Amt
es muss einfach irgendwie jemand mal
Verantwortung übernehmen sich vielleicht
auch mal entschuldigen für das was
passiert ist Behördengänge wollen
sorgsam geplant sein war eine Termin im
Bürgeramt online buchen will muss meist
zwei Monate warten mindestens das geht
seit Jahren so wer es eilig hat und per
Telefon versucht braucht Glück und
Geduld
finden sich in der warte
Schlange das Grundproblem ist dass wir
ein verwaltungsdesaster in dieser Stadt
angerichtet haben über viele Jahre seit
20 Jahren seit der letzten
Verwaltungsreform das eben diese
organisierte Unverantwortlichkeit und
Unzuständigkeit pflegt wer zum Beispiel
Müll auf der Straße anzeigt könnte
Opfer des legendären Behörden Ping Pons
werden eine Behörde meldet das Problem
einer anderen damit geht der Fall gerne
als erledigt und passieren tut nichts
trotzdem zieht es viele nach Berlin auch
Unternehmen die Start-up-Szene ist in
keiner anderen deutschen Stadt größer
und Amazon baut gerade eine mächtige
Zentrale der Sommer in Berlin ist
großartig die Stadt hat jede Menge
Wasser sehr viel Grün und natürlich jede
Menge Kultur Monika Bonvicini ist
Künstlerin zurzeit bespielt sie die Neue
Nationalgalerie Berlins bedeutendsten
Bau der Moderne Mitte der 80er ist sie
in die Stadt gekommen seither lebt und
arbeitet sie hier
die Menge an Freiräume die es damals gab
es natürlich einen der Gründe warum so
viele Leute hier gekommen sind und warum
ich auch immer zurückgekommen bin
doch die Freiräume werden kleiner
steigende Mieten verdringen junge
Kreative auch das kann zur Verzweiflung
treiben das wäre schön wenn es
einerseits gleichzeitig diese
anarchistische behalten würde andere
Seite ein bisschen ordentlicher und ein
bisschen funktionierendes ist
Anarchie und Ordnung den Berliner
machten Kern Freiheit und eine
funktionierende stadtvereinen die
Erwartungen zumindest sind enorm
ja am 12 Februar hat Berlin wieder
einmal die Wahl der Landeswahlleiter
sagt er habe diesmal ein doppeltes
Sicherheitsnetz gespannt
so Heinz du jetzt noch mal mit
sportlichem ja Deutschland ist erstmals
seit 17 Jahren wieder Hockey Weltmeister
bei den Herren im Finale der WM in
Indien siegte die Mannschaft gegen
Titelverteidiger Belgien mit fünf zu
vier im Penalty schießen am Ende der
regulären Spielzeit stand ist 3:3 das
deutsche Team um Trainer Andre Henning
hatte einen 0:2 Rückstand aufgeholt beim
food-out wurde Torwart Sean Paul
Danneberg zum Helden er parierte drei
penalties und sicherte Deutschland den
dritten WM-Titel
Deutschlands Handballer haben die
Weltmeisterschaft auf dem 15 Platz
beendet in Stockholm gewann die
Mannschaft von Alfred gieslerson gegen
Norwegen mit 28 zu 24
überragender Mann auf dem Platz war
einmal mehr Torwart Andreas Wolf der mit
zahlreichen Paraden die Grundstein für
den Erfolg legte
die Fußball-Bundesliga Ergebnisse von
heute Leverkusen hat 0:2 gegen Dortmund
verloren Schalke und Köln trennten sich
torlos 0:0
Tennisprofi Novak Djokovic hat die
Australian opening Melbourne gewonnen
der 35-Jährige Serbe besiegte im Finales
der fernostizipas aus Griechenland in
drei Sätzen mit seinem 22 Triumph bei
einem Grand Slam Turnier die Djokovic
mit Rekordhalter Rafael Nadal gleich
zudem ist Djokovic nun auch wieder die
Nummer eins der Tennis Weltrangliste
eine Woche vor Beginn der
Weltmeisterschaft hat Lena Dürr ihren
ersten Weltcup Slalom gewonnen nach dem
ersten Lauf im tschechischen
Spindlermühle hatte die 31-Jährige noch
auf Platz 2 hinter Michaela shiffrin
gelegen im zweiten Lauf holte sie auf
und gewann am Ende mit 600 Vorsprung
[Applaus]
noch mehr Erfolge aus deutscher Sicht
gab es in Oberhof beim Rodeln und in St
Moritz im Skeleton und Bob die
winterbergerin Laura Nolte hat immonobob
den ersten deutschen WM-Titel gewonnen
im selben Wettbewerb fuhr die
Thüringerin Lisa buckwitz auf den
dritten Platz
im Zweierbob konnten Johannes Lochner
und Angie war Georg Fleischhauer den
Favoriten Francesco Friedrich stoppen
und erstmals den WM-Titel gewinnen zum
Abschluss der scannen WM haben sich
Susanne Kreher und Christopher den Titel
im Mixed Team Event gesichert und auch
bei der Heimweh im Oberhof für das
deutsche rodelteam mit einer Bereiter
Max Langenhahn und den Doppelsitzern
Toni Eckert Sascha Benecken zum WM-Titel
[Applaus]
und jetzt ein Liebling der
musikredaktionen beim Pop Radio so
Fenster überhaupt noch musikredaktionen
gibt und nicht der
mainstream-computer die Auswahl der
größten super Hits besorgt aber auch der
würde Sam Smith hoch und runter spielen
diesen globalen Popstar der praktisch
alles erreicht hat Multimillionen
Verkäufe Grammys einen Oscar Smith ist
gerade mal 30 Jahre alt und hat jetzt
etwas anderes vor etwas das am Ende
wichtiger sein dürfte als alle
Musikpreise dieser Welt zusammen Sam
Smith will mithelfen dass wir alle uns
so akzeptieren wie wir sind
[Musik]
nicht ich habe die Musik erwählt sondern
sie mich sie kommt aus der Tiefe meines
Herzens
Sam Smith Outing als weder weiblich noch
männliche Sängerin machte 2019
Schlagzeilen
Sams aktueller Song an Holi feiert
quiris Selbstverständlichkeit und
dominiert die Charts in den USA oder
Ungarn
Communitys zunehmend entrechtet sind
okay beginnen wir was treibt sie an ich
bin nicht religiös aber ich bin
spirituell als Kind besuchte ich eine
katholische Schule das hat mich geprägt
so dass ich manchmal wenn ich über große
Emotionen schreibe religiöse Wörter
einfließen lasse in meine Texte
[Musik]
anders sein niemand ist das
auch der Titel seines neuen vierten
Albums Gloria ist nicht zufällig
Gloria ist eine Hymne die ich für mein
jüngeres ich geschrieben habe in der
Schule hörte ich ständig Gloria in
excelteo und als ich älter wurde Laura
branigans Gloria in Schwulenbars Gloria
ist der weibliche spirit in mir der sagt
gib nicht auf mach weiter
[Musik]
sanft süßer Mainstream Pop über
enttäuschte männliche Liebe bringt Sam 4
Grammys
[Musik]
heute fordert Sam gender neutrale
Kategorien für Kunstpreise und Eck damit
immer noch an gerade wurde Sam von
US-Präsident Joe Biden eingeladen zur
Feier des neuen Gesetzes zum Schutz der
Ehe für alle immerhin
[Musik]
das war ein wichtiger Tag für die queere
Community als queere Person fühlt es
sich oft so an es geht einen Schritt
vorwärts und zehn zurück deshalb war es
gut Teil eines positiven Tages zu sein
ein Tag der Freude
and powerment das ist das worauf Sam
jetzt setzt und das ist hörbar auf Sams
neuen wunderbaren Album
[Musik]
Berlin
zur Hölle willst Du jemand anderen
lieben wenn du nicht in der Lage bist
dich selbst zu lieben singt Sam Smith
the das ist mein persönlichstes Album
das sagen ja viele Musikstars über ihr
neustes Werk bei Smith trifft es zu
dann gucken wir jetzt in die Woche die
vor uns liegt auf was wir da besonders
achten sollten zeigt Lena sünderbruch
[Musik]
Bus und Bahn fahren ohne
mund-nasenschutz am Donnerstag wird
bundesweit die maskenpflicht im
Fernverkehr fallen außerdem laufen die
verpflichtenden corona-maßnahmen am
Arbeitsplatz aus ob maskentests oder
Homeoffice bleiben kann der Arbeitgeber
dann frei entscheiden
ebenfalls am Donnerstag will beinahe die
gesamte EU-Kommission nach Kiew Reisen
auch deren Präsidentin von der Leyen
später soll EU-Ratspräsident Michelle
Folgen bei dem Gipfeltreffen mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski wird
es vor allem um die weitere Annäherung
seines Landes an die EU gehen
in Los Angeles werden am Sonntag die
begehrtesten Musikpreise der Welt
verliehen die Grammys auch einige
deutsche können sich Hoffnungen machen
auf der Liste der Nominierten stehen
unter anderem die Berliner
Philharmoniker und die Geigerin
Anne-Sophie Mutter
[Musik]
und die Wetteraussichten zum Start in
die neue Woche morgen wechselt oder
stark bewölkt mit vielen Regen Schnee
und Graupelschauern dazu starker bis
stürmische Westwind an der See und im
Bergland schwere Sturmböen ein bis 9
Grad in den nächsten Tagen weiterhin
sehr wechselhaft in höheren Lagen mit
Schnee am Mittwoch wieder stürmisch
Höchstwerte ein bis acht Grad
eins wenn das kein fernsehwetter ist
durch die kommende Woche begleiten Sie
hier im Fernsehen eine gallinek und
Gundula Gause
heute Express vom gesamten Team hier bei
uns auch dem hinter den Kameras vielen
Dank fürs Interesse und ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]